c'est ici dans ces bâtiments
fonctionnels que les engins matra ont
installé à toulouse le centre
d'intégration de leur secteur spatial
centre qui va avoir pour principale
activité la fabrication du satellite au
ts orbitale de tests satellite satellite
européen de communication qui sera
lancée en juin 1977
qu'est ce qui a motivé cette
décentralisation
c'est ce que nous explique le directeur
général d engins matra et bien toulouse
est déjà devenu une grande capitale
spatiale
grâce à la promotion du cnes et
matraques est une des sociétés les plus
en pointe dans ce domaine se devait de
venir à toulouse
nous nous y étions engagés et nous y
sommes venus de bon coeur alors nous
sommes ici dans la salle blanche c'est
là que va s'assurer la fabrication du
satellite au ts oui le satellite ets
c'est le premier grand satellite de
télécommunication commandé par l'europe
toulouse devient donc par le seul fait
que ce satellite sera intégré comme on
dit a semblé ici la capitale des
télécommunications spatiales européenne
ce satellite à nous avons la
responsabilité donc finale de son
intégration
elle sera faite ici on a beaucoup parlé
monsieur lagardère du monopole des
américains au point de vue des
télécommunications avec leurs systèmes
intel sat
alors comment cela se passera t'il avec
l'europe en 77 + 78 eh bien il faut
savoir que c'est une décision politique
de l'europe de ses dix pays qu'ils se
sont associés pour réaliser ce programme
mais nous avons en europe tous les
moyens techniques suffisants et
maintenant également la fusée ariane la
fameuse ariane dont une grande partie
sera également intégré chez matra ici
avec tout cela nous pouvons faire nous
pouvons lancer un satellite de
télécommunications qui concurrencera
tout après les satellites américains les
plus évolués
en quelle année exactement et bien dès
l'année 1977 ce premier satellite
expérimental si vous voulez sera lancé
mais des 79 à satellite européen qui
sera dérivé de celui ci pourra remplir
toutes les fonctions que remplissent les
satellites américains
l'europe des 80 a les moyens techniques
aujourd'hui grâce à des firmes comme la
nôtre grâce à l'action donc de toulouse
a les moyens d'avoir une indépendance
totale en matière de télécommunications
chaleur je voudrais vous demander
combien d'emplois permettra de créer
cette décentralisation de matraques et
bien bien entendu les gens qui sont ici
vont faire travailler des industries
locales
mais ceux qui sont ici attaché
directement au centre matra seront à peu
près une soixantaine dont je précise que
1 car c'est à dire une quinzaine seront
des ingénieurs et techniciens européens
étrangers voyez-vous la langue commune
et là c'est l'anglais mais il y aura
donc pratiquement tous les pays
européens représentés
néanmoins le centre matra représentera
donc les trois quarts la moitié d'entre
eux du reste sont les gens de toulouse
je dois préciser bien sûr que ce sont
essentiellement des ingénieurs et des
techniciens très supérieure